the real housewives of dubai
finally here after like
a year of people being like when are we
getting it when are we getting it when
are we getting it caroline stanberry i'm
going to start with you because it's the
return to bravo
for you the last time bravo viewers saw
you you were moving to dubai so now
we're picking up almost six years later
why was now the time to reintroduce
reality tv cameras to your life
i mean so many reasons i've changed city
i've changed man i've changed life i
mean i've had a complete three what is
it like 180 i'm like just a different
person and everyone says i'm nice enough
believe it or not my not my classmates
but i was gonna say maybe not the ladies
i just spoke to
oh
do tell guys
because she would do things
and say things and then just be like
hold down like i don't know what to talk
about
no surprise we need to surprise we know
that they're shady we know do you think
you had a target on your back coming
into this being kind of an established
personality that the audience is gonna
know
okay
i didn't
you don't think it's genuine girl let me
see
lisa and i on
they jumped on twitter before anybody
had even seen a clip from this show um
to call you a snake
why would they call you a snake and
what's your response to being called the
snake
i don't know why they called me a snake
to be honest why did you need to put
that out there before people even get
their eyes on this show
you know what
i was responding to
a comment that was made um you know and
if who the cat fit let them wear it
aiona why is caroline stanberry a snake
because she's leaders
she's light around so that's why
like lisa say did you say the cat fits
the cat what did you say oh i said who
the cat face let them wear it or who the
shoot fits the shoe fits wear cinderella
there we go
i feel like i've taken quite a lot from
them over the past however long
um and maybe now i've just decided i'm
not going to take anymore they don't
like that and i'm just you know i'm very
happy in my friend group and i have a
very strong connection to the other
ladies
and i think at some point you have to
say enough and i when you do hear things
about your husband your work you're this
you're that you know i wonder who is
this name
i mean i think fans will be rooting for
you and i on to become a dynamic duo
like down the line because you're both
such
personalities but from the look on your
face that's never gonna happen
i mean hell might freeze over i suppose
but
congratulations to everyone's favorite
milk congrats on becoming this is let me
get this right
yes you could say
[Laughter]
there is a little bit of
early speculation talk that maybe this
is a marriage of convenience not a true
romance what's your response to that
um yawn i've been with him three years i
mean i don't know how convenient when he
lived in
america um that it is to move across
when you know nobody
um
and he is uh
as i said living in with my family made
my family love him we love him and i
think when you know us you understand us
i understand that being 20 years
older as a woman isn't normal for you
know it's not normally the men doing it
but as a mature woman i think a lot of
young men find us sexy a lot of young
men would do it as just society told
tells us we can't well i'm here to say
we can and you know i
you know i don't really care what anyone
else thinks divorced not dead right
yeah
um i think maybe it's also he just loves
you so much and is so affectionate with
you that people are like this is they've
never seen it before like they don't
people aren't used to seeing men share
their feelings so much i've never seen
it before i don't know you know and i do
understand because it's literally i
don't know if you've ever seen that
cartoon pepe look you he is yes
and i'm always i'm the first to go give
me give me a minute give me a second but
i wake up like that when there are no
cameras i go to bed like that i'm like
please get the back
off
but he can't and it's very sweet and
it's endearing and why are we as a
society trying to bash that out of him
good question now don't let them
you can't i don't think she's going to
have we met this lady in dubai the women
are far from submissive
most of the women are running this town
now we know who we're dealing with here
um we got to wrap this up but looking
ahead to what you lived and what the
audience is about to experience share
kind of what you're excited about and
what you're dreading stan berry are you
delivering us the ladies of london
reunion we all want on this show at some
point well yes they're all a lot of them
came for my wedding so they did um i'm
really excited for you to see that
because also for me to watch it back
because it was obviously just happened
and i don't even have my wedding video
so i presume it's going to be a bit like
that
and i want the world to see that my
relationship does make sense with my
husband and actually shame on you all
for discrediting um him before he's even
got going in and giving us older women
um
hope for the future for anyone that's
out there that's not happy where they
are just to say you're not a tree if you
don't like where you are move i took a
chance i moved to the middle east i met
the man of my dreams i'm very happy he
doesn't look maybe the way
you all feel comfortable with him
looking
but we are happy
[Music]